MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to "Root Access," the
show on GDL about startups.
My name is Martin Omander.
And I work for Google
Developer Relations.
And today, I'm joined by no
other than Don Dodge, a fellow
Googler and longtime investor
and startup advocate.
By the way, thank you, everybody
out there, for all
of your great comments on
our YouTube videos.
And we are actually, Don, going
to address some of those
comments today.
DON DODGE: Great.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So we actually had an episode
a couple of weeks ago called
"Startup Founders Who Say,
I Have a Great Idea,
But," dot, dot, dot.
So in that episode, you said
that entrepreneurs shouldn't
be afraid of sharing
their ideas--
or they shouldn't be afraid
of getting them stolen.
And that generated a lot of
comments, great comments.
So could you narrow it
down for us a bit?
Are you saying startups
should tell just
anybody about their ideas?
Isn't that risky business?
DON DODGE: Well, I think sharing
your ideas with other
founders and other investors
is a good idea because,
generally, the people
want to help you.
And they'll give you advice.
They'll expose you to things
that you haven't thought of.
They'll take your idea and makes
you think about how to
use it in a different market
segment or with a different
customer base or different
users.
So more times than not, you
learn more from sharing your
idea than you do by
keeping it secret.
To the question of do people
steal ideas, generally, no,
they don't, for several
reasons.
The first one is they're too
busy doing their own idea and
their own thing to be distracted
by your idea.
So that's the first reason
people don't
generally steal ideas.
They might see some concepts
in what you're doing or UI
approaches or something that
might be interesting that they
can incorporate into
their idea.
But I wouldn't classify that
as stealing your idea.
It's just sort of adopting some
principles into their own
idea that make sense for them.
So very rarely have I seen
any ideas stolen.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
One viewer, Hazael Reyes, said
that ideas can be stolen.
He's seen it many times.
And he recommends patenting your
idea before it's stolen.
Is that something you
see among startups?
DON DODGE: Well, first of all,
no, I don't see ideas stolen
very often.
But second to the question of
patents, generally, they're a
waste of time and money.
People don't understand how much
time it takes to get a
patent and how expensive it is
in terms of lawyer fees and
your own time in writing the
patent and all of the defenses
to get a patent.
It typically takes two to four
years to get a patent issued
and can cost from $25,000 to
$100,000 for the process of
getting a patent.
So generally, a startup is
either out of business or
wildly successful and
acquired before the
patents ever get issued.
So unless your idea is really,
really new and different,
patents don't typically
make a lot of sense.
And, oh, one other point.
Let's say you're successful
and you get a
patent issued to you.
Well, congratulations, now
you have to defend it.
So if someone violates your
patent, now you have to hire
lawyers to go defend
the patent.
So that's going to cost you more
time and more money to
defend the patent.
So it's much more expensive
and takes more time than
people realize and, generally,
not worth it.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
you say you have
to defend your patent.
What happens if you
don't defend it?
DON DODGE: Then you lose it,
because if someone violates
your patent knowingly and
openly, then you lose your
patent because you
didn't defend it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
So big costs that you
may not see upfront.
Interesting.
So another viewer of
MrBinaryKode--
I love your username,
by the way--
responded, commented, really?
So ideas can't be stolen?
Tell that to Bill Gates
and Steve Jobs.
So, well, we've all heard
these legends, right?
How Steve Jobs was allegedly
inspired by windowing systems
he had seen at Xerox PARC.
He built a Mac OS.
Then Bill Gates was inspired
by Mac OS to build Windows.
Don't those examples show
the danger of sharing?
DON DODGE: Well, I think the
key word there is "inspired
by." So it wasn't stolen.
It wasn't copied exactly.
It was inspired by.
And by the way, Bill Gates and
Steve Jobs also had their
ideas copied or inspired.
So that's the way
software works.
That's the way technology
works.
You take several different
ideas and put them
together in a new way.
They may have been inspired
by existing ideas.
But you create something new.
So if ideas are really stolen,
then there are courts that
decide those things and
award damages and
that kind of thing.
So I don't think in the startup
world, stealing ideas
is a big problem.
And I think inspiration
is the key word there.
And typically, you see ideas
that get adopted or adapted or
inspired and result in taking
that idea and incorporating it
into your own product and
probably doesn't compete at
all with the original idea.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, I see.
I know, Don, you were involved
in Napster some years ago.
Was that idea stolen?
Did you guys steal that
idea from anywhere?
DON DODGE: Well, Napster got
accused of stealing other
things, not ideas
but maybe music.
But, no, Napster was the basis
of several other ideas.
So like FTP, the file transfer
protocol, that existed before.
The instant messaging
system and protocol,
that existed before.
All of those sort of
ideas existed, but
in different ways.
So all Napster did was took
the FTP protocol for file
transfer and took the instant
messaging kind of concept and
a few others and put them
together in a way that was
totally new.
So we didn't invent anything.
But we took existing ideas and
concepts and put them together
in a new way and focused them
on a completely new market.
So nothing was invented.
Nothing was stolen.
But Napster was a conglomeration
of different
ideas that created something
entirely new.
And that's generally
what happens.
That's what Steve Jobs did
with the graphical user
interface and what Bill Gates
did with Windows.
They took existing concepts
and just made them into
something new and different.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Finally, Don, Matt [? Perry ?]
asked, if you're a startup
founder, you're doing
something, you have an idea,
you've gotten started, and
then you notice that somebody
else has a patent on your
idea, is that game over?
What do you do?
DON DODGE: Well, I think it's
game over if you're trying to
do the same thing in the same
market, the same kind of
product that is patented.
That's probably not
a good idea.
But if you're starting something
that uses the same
concepts in a different
market, in a different
product, you're probably
OK for several reasons.
First one is startups are so
small and insignificant that
the patent holder probably will
not be aware of you or
care about what you're doing,
at least initially.
Unless you're wildly successful
with hundreds of
millions of users or hundreds
of millions of dollars in
revenue, they're probably
not going to care.
Secondly, if you're in a
completely different market
segment-- for example, if the
original patent was for
something in manufacturing and
you use it in entertainment or
you use it in retail or
something that's sort of a
completely different market--
generally, they're not going
to care because it's so
expensive to sue and
defend the patent.
If you're doing something
else, it doesn't matter.
So it does matter if you're
violating a patent that's in
the same market with the same
kind of product that's going--
then you're going to
run into trouble.
And that probably
is game over.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
Thank you, Don.
And thank you all
for watching.
Please keep those comments
coming in on YouTube, comments
or questions you'd like us to
pick up in future episodes.
Finally, I am also
a developer.
And I built a lot of stuff using
Google Cloud Platform.
I think it's a great platform.
And life is too short to build
stuff anywhere else.
And as a special deal for you,
Root Access viewers, we have a
$2,000 credit that you can
go and get and get
started on the platform.
Just follow the on-screen
instructions.
And good luck on the
Cloud Platform.
And thank you for watching.
And see you next time.
Bye.